we're gonna have a lot of questions for
our next guest i know many of you will
metta how are you good good how are you
jason
i am good let's start out with who are
you
who are you who is medecovin
the person who spent 69 million dollars
on an nft who are you
um as medic woman metacon is
a year old now so i've been a
metaverse avatar right like and i've
been very
um active the nft space since 2017
right and um yeah i just i just uh
think this um this life
of of of meta code is completely
something that i got to experiment with
and i'm just running with it but before
uh
matakovin uh i'm vignesh right like and
i've been in the space since 2013 i
built several companies i built a
bitcoin atm company based out of canada
uh yeah i i've done several things in
the industry before
and i'm assuming that you have
uh an enormous net worth because you
spent 70 million dollars on an nft
so how did you make all this money were
you an early bitcoiner or you got an
early on ethereum or you sold a company
what
what did you do in your day job that
gave you the ability to spend this much
money
and capture everybody's imagination so
so so definitely did not
make money out of startups uh it's it's
quite hard
uh i think tell me about it like
coinbase is just having the exit right
so it's not like a lot of companies in
our space has
had an exit yet so
most of the money i've made um like all
of the money i've made
is is through crypto right like so i i
started with nothing
um i started uh participating as a
escrow agent in the bitcoin talk forums
back in 2013
so i was the middleman and then that
service grew to a extent
where it became kind of an exchange and
then
i took that money a little money i had
and invested in ethereum and when the
crowd sale came on
and then from there i like you know that
that mental model is what i live with so
i'm not a maximalist
i i look for new technologies i think
it's a beautiful
uh two things right one is this is a
free market of ideas
and it's uh it's it's free
like capitalism right like it's
completely uh
unrestricted so what it allows it it
allows anyone to
invest in high growth startups at a very
very early stage which is unique to our
system because i don't think i'd be in
the cap table of
i'm not in the capital of coinbase right
so it's not it's not every day that we
get access to
high growth uh investments like that and
i did get it so i
i invested in ethereum and then uh on
polka dot
and and last year flow and and several
other um
interesting blockchains also
and you have over 1600 bitcoin atms
all over the globe for with bit access
is that correct
uh yeah that's true but you know like
i'm not with the company anymore
uh when i left the company we had maybe
around 600
uh so this 2016 end of 2016.
but the good part was the first year
2014 we put around
a hundred a teams around the world and
and
and it just scaled quite a bit since
then